our new book is scaling up excellence
and it's about what it takes to spread a
little bit of excellence from those who
have it to those who don't so it could
be scaling up a start-up or it could be
spreading something good like practices
to reduce the number of infections or
preventable deaths in the hospital from
units who have it to those who don't
scaling is viewed as a talent
individuals some of them know how to
scan others don't know how to scale our
hope is our book persuades readers that
you really need to make scaling into a
competency you can't scale up excellence
in a team there's no way you're going to
be promoted to run a business unit or a
department you can't scale up excellence
there there's no way you're going to
move up in the organization it's the
same thing for founders you've poured
your life and heart into your company
you can't scale that up you're actually
going to essentially get into a dead-end
it turns out that if you're going to
spread excellence you have to clear out
the bad stuff first because bad is so
much stronger than good and there's all
sorts of evidence that bad behavior is
it's more contagious it's more
long-lasting it packs a bigger wall up
and so so as a result when you're a good
leader the first thing you got to do is
get rid of the junk the cheating the
laziness the the people who are I they
might be nice people who are incompetent
if you don't get rid of that and
sometimes it's just pure cognitive load
it's just pure complexity so people are
feel like they're walking around and
muck and can't get anything done so
you've got to clear that stuff out
before you can spread excellence for us
as social scientists excellence simply
means people do the right thing even
when nobody is looking over their
shoulder if you have layers of cops
policing your effort in an enterprise
that's not excellence but when people do
the right thing even without others
looking over their shoulder that's when
you can truly outdistance competitors
that's when you can truly exceed what
customers expect a few for us the
mindset is if you will a predisposition
to action people instantly understand
what's sacred in an enterprise they
instantly know the one thing they'll do
without even asking a question and
conversely they're very aware of what's
taboo the one thing they'll never ever
do and you can quickly find out what the
mindset of a company is by asking these
questions what's sacred what's taboo and
if that's not clear and if that's not
understood by people then people won't
act instead they'll wait they'll wait
for the boss to tell them what to do
they'll wait for rules for policies and
as a result they won't actually take any
initiative and so what you need is you
need a clear minds
you're always thinking do I need to be
more standardized ernet less
standardized and that decision is
absolutely essential to the success of
an organization in a new marketplace for
a new set of problems
a good example would be IKEA which in
many parts of the world grew fabulously
successful by having you know that sort
of horrible experience where you jam it
in your car and you take it home and you
assemble it and then you have some
assembly but not much other parts of the
world when they moved into the Chinese
market where where the the the mindset
in China was not do it yourself it was
do it for me they really cranked up the
delivery and the assembly services
because it didn't fit culturally for
everyday lessons for on-the-ground
managers and leaders if I was going to
pick the most important single
day-to-day idea in the book is big team
suck and the reason and we have
excellent evidence that when you go from
four or five people especially 10 11 12
13 all sorts of bad things happen
essentially the problem is it's kind of
a mathematical and cognitive load
problem so if you've got to keep track
of the emotions of three or four other
people and coordinate your activities
with them it's not that hard if you look
at the bath that you go to 11 the the
load of both coordinating and keeping
sort of in emotional tune with another
10 people it's virtually impossible we
our brains aren't big enough and so if
you look at what it takes to have a
great team it's usually four or five
people so the average combat team fire
fight fire team one leader three you
know sort of foot soldiers McKinsey
Engagement Team one engagement leader
three sort of consultants and when you
get 10 11 12 things start falling apart
the common mistake organizations make
here is when they scale they realize ah
the only thing we need are the stars
the others they're dispensable they're
irrelevant they're superfluous but allow
me to drawn an analogy think of climbing
Mount Everest a few people summit
Everest but what makes it possible for
them to summit Everest who's actually
very essential for you to get to the top
you need the sharpest no Sherpas no
summit so if you want me to think of the
summit ears that is the Stars and you
forgive the Sherpas you're never going
to get to the summit so smart scaling
also means that you pay attention to
your cadre or corps of Sherpas